je crois que c'est le bon sens et était
le bon sens de le faire le plus vite
possible et donc il y à un mois quand
nous avons eu notre première rencontre
de crise à matignon le 27 février un peu
plus d'un mois maintenant ils auront dû
prendre cette bonne décision même de
manière progressive
je regrette ce changement de pied
manifestement ce changement de tactique
ou de stratégie peu importe du
gouvernement qui en fait est simplement
l'aveu l'aveu que on a sous-estimé les
besoins en masques dans notre pays et
surtout on a pris un peu en otage les
français qui auraient mérité sûrement
une meilleure réponse institutionnelle
vous vous estimez que la crise a été mal
gérée au moins au début par le
gouvernement et notamment sur cette
question je ne suis pas dans l'esprit
polémique
à ce stade nous posons des questions
nous l'avons fait encore tout à l'heure
sur des réquisitions qui ont lieu en
bourgogne franche comté il y à 48 heures
non nous faisons notre travail
le moment venu l'heure du bilan sera
intéressante pour l'ensemble des
français pour éviter que des erreurs
puissent reproduire
manifestement je ne sais pas s'il ya eu
la préparation d'un père ici dans la
curie éventuellement ce sont des mots
forts je le reconnais mais il est clair
que sur ce problème par pratique des
masques on a sous-estimé manifestement
l'intérêt pour les français pour nos
concitoyens de les porter au plus vite
et tout à l'heure vous avons posé une
question pour les ehpad notamment pour
les personnes âgées qui meurent
malheureusement en silence aujourd'hui
dans ces établissements pour beaucoup
d'entre eux eh bien il s'agissait aussi
d'équipés beaucoup plus vite
les personnels soignants pour éviter que
la maladie ne rentrent dans ces espaces
confinés où malheureusement il ya eu
beaucoup de victimes
justement un certain nombre d un masque
commandées par les régions étaient
prévus pour pouvoir équiper les ehpad
qu'avez-vous pensé tout à l'heure de la
réponse du gouvernement serait bien ces
masques ils disent nous on a priorisé on
a mis là où il était le plus nécessaires
notamment dans le grand est est ce que
pour vous c'est une réponse
satisfaisante le droit de l'acquisition
est prévue par les ordonnances dans le
cadre des habilitations vous avons donné
au gouvernement simplement pas comme
cela pas sans consultation des élus pas
sans savoir exactement où ces masques
allait être
vrai le pouvoir d'état ne peut pas être
un pouvoir contre les élus locaux nous
devons travailler main dans la main et
je ne vous cache pas que la réponse de
monsieur casta l'air était pour le moins
floue regarde la précision de la demande
de jérôme durain notre sénateur
socialiste sur le sujet donc je regrette
qu'il n'y a pas plus de concertation de
consultation et surtout d'efficacité
pour cette distribution des masques dans
notre pays
patrick kanner également dans
l'actualité la question du traçage
numérique 1 il ya eu dans le monde un
certain nombre de précisions qui ont été
apportées par olivier ferrand cédric
haut sur ce projet qui n'est qu'un
projet pour l'instant est ce que vous
sur le principe vous y être favorables
et notamment pour le déconfinement ce
traçage numérique pourrait-il être utile
je suis inquiet ni favorable ni
défavorable je veux savoir comment les
choses vont se passer et j'ai beaucoup
apprécié le rapport de la cnil la
commission nationale informatique et
libertés qui s'est prononcé aujourd'hui
même en disant cela ne pouvait se faire
que sur la base de technique rassurante
par exemple bluetooth pour être précis
sur les smartphones que ça ne pouvait se
faire qu'avec le consentement des
individus est donc une manière
finalement d'encourager le volontariat
sur cette question et puis je n'oublie
pas aussi qu'il y a un quart des
français qui n'ont pas de téléphone
capable d'amener des applications
recteur numérique la traîne fracture
numérique qui est qui est réel donc
manifestement il faudra une loi et c'est
ça la conclusion de ce propos une loi
qui doit être discuté en toute sérénité
avec le temps nécessaire tant au sénat
qu'à l'assemblée nationale fait une
véritable loi une dernière question sur
et bien le tribut qui est payé à part un
certain nombre d'élus il ya notamment la
mort du maire de saint-louis dans le
haut rhin qui soulève une vague
d'émotion certains élus remettent en
cause et bien notamment la campagne des
municipales qu'en pensez vous je pense
qu'aujourd'hui avec le recul tout le
monde comprend qu'il n'aurait pas fallu
organiser ce premier tour et qu'on
aurait même dû arrêter la campagne
plusieurs jours avant la date fatidique
du 15 mars on a exposé de très nombreux
français
quatre cent cinquante mille français ont
tenu les 69 mille bureaux de vote dans
ce pays
et manifestement il y a eu des
infections par ses contacts avec les
votants donc tout ceci montre bien qu'il
ya eu de la préparation et que peut être
au sommet de l'état la bonne décision
n'a pas été prise
quelles que soient les contacts quelles
que soient les éventuelles pressions la
bonne décision pour le pays aurait été
de reporter ces élections est de ne pas
créer une un grand désordre démocratique
qui vient se rajouter à la crise
économique sociale et surtout sanitaires
que nous vivons aujourd'hui